[Musique]
nous avons aujourd'hui un climat social
tout à fait préoccupant
un climat politique instable
on ne peut pas se satisfaire que six
mois après le début d'un mouvement
social
il y est toujours autant de violence et
que la situation de tension à la
situation de tension se lit aussi
palpable aussi intense d'entreprise ça
fait plus de six mois que ça dure dans
notre pays
avec cette crise qu dont il n'a pas
apporté de réponses sociales pour
apaiser cette colère et dont il n'arrive
pas à assurer et et à rétablir
l'autorité en france mais mais regardez
comment maintenant on observe la france
depuis l'étranger mais c'est une honte
ce qui se passe si on avait dès le
départ enrayer le phénomène en écoutant
les français qui étaient contre cette
augmentation de taxes sur les carburants
ces retraités que vous avez vraiment
matraque et en augmentant la csg et en
désindexant les retraites peut-être
qu'on n'en serait pas là
ona laisser s'installer la violence dans
notre pays
ona baisser la garde ona donner moins de
valeur à la notion d'autorité quand on a
cédé aux extrémistes violents à notre
dame des landes
on a lancé un message du trop longtemps
les manifestations sont pollués perturbé
par ces blacks blocs ces cas sauf que
l'on dit venir d'ailleurs y compris
d'autres pays européens où d'autres pays
du monde
seulement pour pouvoir casser détruire
abîmé il est clair que le gouvernement
est très en difficulté sur le maintien
de l'ordre public mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui malheureusement c'est
l'expression démocratique pacifique de
toutes les manifestations qui est mené
c'est pas depuis cinq mois il n'a pas
pris les bonnes décisions et il n'a pas
donné aux forces de l'ordre les moyens
de leur action il n'y a aucune raison
chez désolé et surtout pas dans les
forces de l'ordre quand on a rien à se
reprocher dans les fractures un portail
et notamment d'un hôpital
donc il faut arrêter toujours de trouver
les bonnes excuses ou excuser ce qui
n'est pas excusable
moi je demande au président de la
république que tout soit mis en oeuvre
pour qu'effectivement on puisse enrayer
cela on ne peut plus accepter puisqu'il
y a énormément de répercussions sur
l'économie
il y en aura sur la croissance et sur
l'image de la france à l'étranger